HERE WITH REACTION, AUTHOR OF
THE BEST-SELLING BOOK "SPEAKING
FOR MYSELF," FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR SARAH SANDERS.
LIE, SMEAR, SLANDER, CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, BESMIRCH.
IT’S ALL COMING.
THIS DEFINES THEM AND THEN THE
THREATS.
WE ARE GOING TO PACK THE COURT.
WE’RE GOING TO GET RID OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
WE’LL IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT
EVERY DAY.
THIS IS NOW THE PARTY OF ANARCHY
TO ME, SARAH SANDERS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HASN’T EVEN
NAMED WHO HE WILL NOMINATE TO
THE SUPREME COURT AND THEY HAVE
ALREADY STARTED AGGRESSIVELY AND
VICIOUSLY ATTACKING
JUDGE BARRETT, ONE OF THE
POTENTIAL NOMINEES.
A VERY CONSERVATIVE, STRONG
WOMAN.
THEY ARE ATTACKING HER FOR HER
CHRISTIAN FAITH.
LET’S NOT FORGET THESE ARE THE
SAME LIBERALS WHO LECTURE US
ABOUT EMPOWERING WOMEN.
WHEN THE TRUTH IS THEY ARE
NOTHING BUT LIARS AND HYPOCRITES
WHO ARE ONLY TRYING TO EMPOWER
THEMSELVES AND THEIR RADICAL
AGENDA.
THIS IS A TIME FOR US TO SEND A
CLEAR AND STRONG MESSAGE THAT WE
WILL NOT TOLERATE THE LIBERAL
MOB.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL STAND UP TO
THEM.
HE HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE PARTY TO
DO THAT WITH HIM.
WE ARE GOING TO FIX THE COURT
AND FILL THE SEAT.
HE ABSOLUTELY HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO DO
IT.
HE SHOULD.
HE HAS TO STAND UP AND CONTINUE
FIGHTING AGAINST THIS RADICAL
LEFT LIBERAL MOB THAT THINKS
THAT THEY GET TO CONTROL AND RUN
OUR COUNTRY WHEN THEY DON’T.
>> Sean: IF THEY TRY TO
ELIMINATE THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
AND THEY ARE THREATENING COURT
PACKING AND THEY ARE THREATENING
TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT EVERY
DAY, HAVEN’T THEY JUST THROWN
DOWN WITH THE MOB?
>> THAT’S WHAT THEY HAVE BECOME.
THEY HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY AND
TOTALLY OWNED BY THE RADICAL
LEFT.
LET’S NOT PERMITTED THINK THAT
JOE BIDEN, IF HE SOMEHOW MANAGES
TO WIN, WILL BE RUNNING
ANYTHING.
HE WILL BE COMPLETELY AND
TOTALLY CONTROLLED BY THE
LIBERAL LEFT AND THE RADICAL
MOB.
LOOK WHO THEY TROTTED OUT FRONT
AND CENTER TO BE ONE OF THE
FIRST PEOPLE TO RESPOND AND COME
OUT.
IT WAS AOC.
SHE WILL BE JUST AS MUCH IN
CONTROL AS ANYONE ELSE AND I
THINK THAT SHOULD BE TERRIFYING
FOR EVERY AMERICAN AND CERTAINLY
FOR EVERY WOMAN CONSERVATIVE
WOMEN NEED TO STAND
UP AND FIGHT BACK AS MUCH AS